so this started 10 years ago as a radio
play and I would like to understand
Charlie why you were a little reluctant
when you were approached to make it into
a movie well it was something we called
a sound play it was a staged radio play
and the idea was that there was nothing
on stage to look at other than the
actors reading there was a Foley artist
and there was Carter Burwell conducting
his musicians and the imagery was to be
created in the audience's mind that was
how it was written so that was how it
was written that was was what it was
written to be so when when I was
approached to do it I mean I wasn't
against it I just thought we'd have to
throw out that element which I quite
liked well we had been working at a
studio called starburns industries where
we produced animated television content
for shows on Adult Swim and another
example is community on NBC and and we'd
worked in this sort of comedy realm and
we were looking for opportunities to
broaden the horizon of stop-motion being
able to sort of take the the medium of
stop-motion and explore more adult
stories and and when we got an
opportunity to when I got an opportunity
to read this script it seemed I was a
huge fan of Charlie's as well and it was
just a beautiful script and it seemed
like a great opportunity to explore that
but it wasn't easy to get funding for
this this is really an independent film
and Paramount picked it up out of
Telluride in Toronto and really was
excited about it but that's that took a
while to get to that place explain some
of the reasons why this sort of breaks a
lot of the rules of what animation is
supposed to be we we tried to get
traditional financing we went to a
couple different places and it just
didn't work out for us so we turned to
Kickstarter we we did a 60-day campaign
and Duke and I had gone through the
studio when we found
that's from previous shows and old
puppets and we cobbled it all together
and made this three-minute video just
talking about what we really wanted to
do with this and 60 days later we raised
four hundred and six thousand that's
very good on Kickstarter so that was
enough to get you started
all right so explain a little bit about
the animation and Charlie you know how
you directed this together and how many
stages there were how many animators
there were I loved I loved going to
visit these places and seeing all the
little black boxes my role as the
director along with Duke was to create
the movie so you know we worked on the
design of the puppets we worked on the
design of the sets we we did an animatic
we recorded the actors you use the same
actors use the same actors we recorded
them and together which is an unusual
thing for animation you know we got the
production going a lot animation is very
front loaded because especially a
low-budget animation like ours because
we didn't you can't make you have to
know what going in you know down to the
frame what it is you're going to shoot
you don't have retakes and you can't
really make mistakes so you do the
animatic which is kind of basically the
movie the storyboards put to the dialog
in real time so you understand what the
movie is going to look like and then you
you you shoot it that's what we did we
had like a like 18 stages we had about
13 animators 18 stages by the end of
production we had eight identical michel
hotel rooms so on each of the different
stages they could be working on
different sequences and the directors
worked with everybody they would go and
they do their rounds about twice a day
one at 11:00 one at 3:00 and they check
in about the shot you know they would
move like for free you did like two
seconds a day or something I was
progressing very slowly they had a goal
of two seconds a day for animator her
I mean they rarely hit that so we
produced about a minute of footage a
week so I have written down the audience
so so what is this 3d printing how did
that help you in this what was that what
was explaining the mechanics of that to
me well when we recorded the actors they
delivered a very subtle small nuanced
vocal performance and so when we were
exploring the creative development of
the puppets we knew early on that we
wanted them to have the greatest range
of facial expressions so we focused on
the eyes is one fact one thing that we
spent a lot of time focusing on but the
other thing is the face and and how it
moves and so we settled on this type of
animation called replacement animation
where the face is split across the eyes
and you have brow pieces and mouth
pieces the mouth pieces are for all the
different phenome and the brow pieces
are for the different expressions of you
know that gives the emotion like the
furrowed and worried and surprised
there's about a hundred and fifty
different top pieces and about a hundred
and fifty different bottom pieces and it
gives the animators millions of possible
combinations to place them and create
the performance okay all right that
answers the question but you also chose
to keep the visible line why did you why
did you guys choose to do that once we
decided to use replacement animation we
didn't want to hide what it is from the
audience we wanted it to be understood
that this was stop-motion animation and
when that type of animation is is used
it's always painted out in post so you
can't see the seams and then you don't
really know what you're looking at they
do a lot of things to polish and remove
things like chatter and the clothing in
the air we kept that there's color
variations in the 3d printed faces which
we
kept and it it gives it a feeling of
being handmade and it gives it a feeling
it gives the characters a feeling of
being manipulated by outside forces and
which they are and it gives it them a
feeling of brokenness and well the other
thing that strikes me is you've just
taken us so much closer to a certain
kind of naturalism than most animation I
don't think I've ever seen any animation
that got this close and the conventional
wisdom is that when you do that you get
to some kind of uncanny valley
they were like or something that makes
people uncomfortable were you worried
about that we were certainly aware of it
it was we had lots of conversations
about it and one thing that we thought
would really help us is is the eyes you
know the eyes is literally being windows
to the soul so to speak so we wanted to
put a lot of attention to make sure that
the eyes felt alive each one of those
eyes you know Michaels 12 inches tall
and so his head is that big and the eyes
are you know like a like a like a little
bead so small in fact that we couldn't
find any like glass eyes that existed
for dolls or anything in the world so
they all had to be individually handmade
and hand-painted and they're moved by
hand individually so they have to stay
together you know it's very meticulous
in tedious and then also we made them
reflective so that they would not only
look moist but also so that they could
have eye lights which humans naturally
have if there's any light source present
humans have this reflective eye light
and so we the cinematographer Joe
Passarella it was like his mission to
make sure that these characters had I
lights and every scene so there were
these little grains of wheat or these
tiny little these tiny little bulbs
super tiny and they would be hidden in
the set in every direction so wherever
the character moved he would have an eye
light Wow that explains a great deal